Vsauce. Five riddles. Four brand names. Three facts.
Two weird products and one project.
It's 5432-
One project from Instructables. Turn your
Super Nintendo it an ultimate gaming
console emulator
that plays NES, Genesis, N64 and more.
You'll need about 200 dollars in
parts, some free time and own legal copies
of the games.
Two weird products.
The first is blood perfume.
It doesn't contain actual human blood,
but they claim the four blood type
scents are somehow
realistically represented.
Second is elephant poop
paper. The great elephant PooPooPaper Company
filters the poop, leaving only the fibers,
grasses, bamboo and fruits that the
elephant couldn't digest.
And no, it doesn't smell.
Three facts.
Honey does not spoil.
Honey found in tombs of Egyptian
pharaohs has been taited by
archaeologist and found edible.
Aegilops is the longest word in the
English language
with all the letters in alphabetical
order. When the CD was invented it was
decided it should be long enough to hold
Beethoven's 9th Symphony at any tempo
on one
disc. Four brand names. Sometimes we refer
to products exclusively by their brand name.
Bubble wrap is actually inflated cushioning.
Dumpsters are front loader waste
containers. Jet skis are stand-up
personal watercrafts.
And velcro is really hook-and-loop fastener.
Five riddles. Mad Gabs are group of words that
don't make sense until you say them
slowly and discover the hidden phrase or name.
For example, "Able Owe Knees
Hand Which."
A Bolognese sandwich.
Here are three Mad Gabs.
"Bigger Scant
Beach Hoosiers."
"Check Can Tub Ends Talk."
"Aim Hiker Owes Cope."
Here's a visual puzzle. What month does this represent?
Finally, here's a riddle from you guys.
"I was walking on a bridge when I met a
man. He tipped his hat
and drew his cane. In this riddle I said his name.
What is it?"
Before we go, here's last week's winner.
Leave your answers in the comments below...
And as always,
thanks for watching.